it's increasingly clear that corporate
America is now the left's ideological
enforcer it couldn't be clearer and it's
not just happening in Silicon Valley
until this week Dennis Finley was an
editor at the Burlington Free Press in
Vermont but the Gannett media giant
unceremoniously fired him this Tuesday
after he tweeted questions about a
Vermont proposal to create a third
gender option for driver's licenses
why'd they do that well then this Finley
joins us tonight to answer that question
Dennis thanks for coming out thank you
sucker
thanks for having me so the reason I
want to talk to you is I was sincerely
I'm not just saying this rhetorically a
little bit confused by your firing since
you didn't attack transgendered people
you didn't even attack the idea of a
third sex on the driver's licenses from
the tweets that I saw but you asked
questions to somebody else on Twitter I
didn't understand how that was out of
bounds well I believe Tucker was out of
bounds because I didn't agree with it I
think it's as simple as that but there's
a very it was a powerful contingent of
speech police out there this is an
extremely liberal state's progressive
state and I kind of galvanized them
unwittingly and it went on and on all
through the weekend and they didn't want
to stop until they had my head on a
platter and they finally got it on
Monday evening but you save Vermont is
liberal but there's nothing liberal
about taking a man's livelihood away
because you disagree with him that's not
liberal that's something else well you'd
have to ask them but I think they think
it's a feather in their cap anytime they
can get rid of somebody who disagrees
with them I think that's what's going on
here but you're a journalist and have
been for a long time and isn't a kind of
key tenant of journalism that you get to
say what you think is true the truth is
a defense truth is a defense you get to
say what is true but in the age we live
in our companies a lot of media
companies say that we're supposed to be
objective impartial etc etc I want to
ask questions I want to raise questions
and raise issues because I think there
are a lot of things going on that we
have to
ask questions about and putting a third
gender on a driver's license is
something that I thought we should ask a
question about so someone on Twitter
said something to the effect I think
this is great or courageous and you said
why is it great and crius courageous
great correct
and I really I believe that if I had
said that is great and courageous
awesome that's great
I don't think we'd be having this
conversation here today Tucker so the
question really isn't about objectivity
they're not asking you to be objective
they're asking you to toe a very
specific line of course they're asking
me to toe the line they're asking me to
agree with them and they're asking me to
they're holding my feet to the fire to
you know make sure that the orthodoxy
wins out and this time you know they
held my feet to the fire until my
company said that's enough you're fired
do you see this as a trend it's
something that I've begun to notice
where big companies have become the
heavies for the cultural left you think
of big companies is conservative but all
of a sudden they're the ones who seem to
be enforcing orthodoxies is that my
imagination no I don't think it is I
think big companies a lot of big media
companies are more or less encouraging
the left I believe that they I don't
think that their objective I don't
believe that they want debate I think
they want us to conform and conform to
the prevailing ideology that's out there
and a prevailing ideology that's out
there is leftist and when the leftists
take you on they're big in number and
people are afraid to say anything
against them so they they often win they
won a little while ago here in Vermont
when they shouted Charles Mary off the
stage yeah in Middlebury when he tried
to give a speech that was on your show I
know so
yeah it's hard to disagree with them
well they take your job away and here we
are in the middle of the winter in your
in Vermont you got no job so our prayers
are with you Dennis good luck I hope you
find something thank thank you
Thanks